if you need a little extra energy or you
need to pay really close attention to
something today here's what you should
do you should make a prediction about
anything it can be a prediction of how
many emails you'll get in the next hour
it could be a prediction about who's
gonna win the baseball game tonight it
could be a prediction of how many
jumping jacks can you do with 60 seconds
make a prediction and then just wait to
see if you were right or not every time
that you make a prediction you get a
little bump of dopamine in the reward
pathways of your brain and the reason
why you get a little dopamine bomb is
that your brain is preparing itself to
learn so we often think of dopamine as
the reward neurochemical when there's
something we really want like a cookie
or a pat on the back and we get this
dopamine hit in anticipation of it so we
think about it as being really related
to pleasure and and fun and satisfaction
but the reason why dopamine feels good
is that the brain is actually trying to
trick us into learning or improving our
strategies for being successful or
getting what we want
so dopamine is going to prime your brain
to pay closer attention to process
information more effectively to be more
engaged with what's going on
and-and-and-and so just make a little
prediction about anything you'll get the
dopamine hit your brain will go into
high gear and you could really use this
in in very strategic ways for example if
you're giving a presentation ask your
audience at the beginning of your
presentation to make a prediction it
could be about your presentation it
could be about something in their own
lives you've given them a dopamine hit
now they're paying attention they're
gonna actually learn more from what
you're about to say so make a prediction
it's a really easy way to get the
benefits and the learning benefit
specifically of a dopamine pump you'll
also just feel happier which is good too
you